the closer people are to you when you're
at your bottom the more they'll work for
you at the bottom but as you pass them
in whatever material thing you're you
know Pursuit is you remind them of the
dreams that they gave up on you go from
being the person who reminds them that
they could go after their dreams to
reminding them that they never went
after them to begin with and then what
happens you go through this period where
no one from your hometown or who who
knew you in the beginning approves and
then what happens is absolute strangers
from the internet who never saw the
beginning become a bigger fan of you
because they can relate to the story but
because you weren't there next door
neighbor they don't feel blame for them
not having achieved whatever yet because
if everyone in your friend group when
you're coming up they see that they have
the exact same access to resources
opportunities that you do and then for
some reason they haven't done something
so it's painful because I think there's
some Sting of inadequacy that they
probably self judge as a result